clashes have broken out between moroccan
security forces and people attempting to
reach
european territory by swimming around
border fences
this week thousands of would-be migrants
forced their way into the spanish
enclave of seouta in north africa
morocco appeared to have loosened its
border controls with the territory
following a diplomatic dispute with
spain
that security has now been stepped up
desperation just outside of zouta would
be migrants scuffle with moroccan
security forces
pushing them back they were blocking the
border
of the spanish enclave as they turned to
night
clashes broke out police eventually
managed to regain control
and disperse the crowds of mostly young
men
[Music]
the desire to get across the border is
great migrants who reach the spanish
enclave
often say they have no choice but to
leave morocco
we come here to look for a better future
than in my country
there we have no rights or anything
there's nothing no work
nothing but what are you going to do
local spanish residents say the
situation is tense
many feel overwhelmed
currently there's so many arriving it's
really unusual
we're in a kind of state of emergency
here and many residents are really
afraid
[Music]
personally i feel safe out on the street
i'm not afraid
but i'm a teacher and at the moment many
of my pupils are not coming to classes
because they're scared those attempting
to swim to serta
are now immediately picked up by spanish
soldiers the number of people crossing
into sota
reached a peak earlier this week with
some 8 000 entering in a single day
spain has since deployed the army to
patrol the border and send the migrants
back
speaking to parliament in madrid spanish
prime minister petra sanchez voted to
restore
order and said that nearly 5 000
migrants had been returned
i remind you that the border with celta
is not only a border between spain and
morocco but
also a european border and that in this
case the lack of control by the american
authorities is not only a lack of
respect towards spain but also towards
the european union
officials in madrid say they are
reinforcing sotas borders
to prevent more rivals
dw correspondent jan philip schweitz is
in the spanish enclave of theater and
says
the tensions there are likely to
continue
it seems like a simple fence between
morocco and spain but it has become
an important symbol of world politics
over the past days
thousands of migrants have swum across
the border you can still
see some of their close here it seems
like the price that spain has to pay for
outsourcing some of its
border protection and paying millions of
euros to morocco
to prevent migrants from passing the
border now during a diplomatic dispute
morocco has started to make use of its
power and has
started to let migrants pass thousands
have arrived over the past days
and the challenge doesn't seem to be
over